letztlich komme heute ja wer hätte
gedacht
zu dem neuen presse luca ich habe mir
die tage was bei amazon bestellt und es
kam gestern hat mir heute noch mal das
unternehmen mit die gekaufte menge
geschrieben und sie kennt das ja
vielleicht schreibt das unternehmen
welche fragen haben durchläuft alle und
sonst kundensupport dieser blabla ab
warum habe ich noch gesagt jeder zeit
ist das unternehmen da keiner wird das
unternehmen nämlich verstellt ist ein
ausländisches unternehmen wenn das heißt
sie können kein deutsch und solche
unternehmen denken immer so dass in den
google übersetzer ganz ganz tolle ideen
ich zeige euch mal was bei der meldung
raus gekommen
hallo luca haben sie ihr akku hülle für
iphone weg 67 bloß schwarz erhalten
haben sie erhalten nicht nur übersetzer
bin ich mit ihr von wohnquartieren frage
der frag mich ob er matthias günstiger
wenn ich mir von möchten wir nur wissen
nämlich auch er war die aktion möchten
wir wissen ich weiß nicht ob ihr wissen
wollt dann aber viel häufiger möchten
wir nun wissen ob sie ihren auftrag
erhalten oder nicht übrigens wenn sie
irgendwelche frage haben antworten wie
einfach auf diese e-mail oder klicken
sie auf den kundendienst link und werde
ich diese forderung sorgen wenn ich sage
nein google setzt so ein schwachsinn
raushaut können sie mir helfen können
warum also leute ich mir dass du
geschickt hat und so der meint bestimmt
das ist schon hart schlechtes deutsch
ich tue mein bestes um hervorragenden
kundenservice zu bieten und das denken
sie über unser akku hülle für iphone
schwarzen wirklich wichtig an annika
linder hat war statt was zu sagen willst
wenn wir eine sekunde nehmen und mir
einen feedback geben weiß ich jetzt
wirklich zu schätzen
leute geht mir doch mal einen feedback
bei den wetten leid bei diesem video da
und bei 100
leute effekt mir ein vergnügen allen
meinen kunden bei allen fragen zu helfen
wenn sie einen becher haben kontaktieren
sie mich und ich werde die so schnell
wie möglich antworten schönen tag sie
werden mich antworten danke danke dass
ich geantwortet werde als ich die melder
noch jeden fall gelesen habe habe ich
mir gedacht okay dinger da musst du auf
jeden fall video darüber machen aber das
wäre ein bisschen zu kurz und für ein
video gewesen deswegen hab ich mir
gedacht die suche noch kunst made
brauchst dich mal an meine kontrakt der
teenager scott may von euch zugeschickt
bekommen habe
apropos was normalerweise schreiben mir
leute male ging wie in welchen pilz zu
sagen fragen oder erklimmen will er
nicht anordnen oder irgendwas davon
wenig macht doch mal wieder das video
oder mal wieder da frau trägt eine video
folgen aber er schreibt einfach selber
geologie asyl in kanada ist ich war im
zimmer mir war dann langweilig ich hole
dass mein iphone und sonys porto und
spritze ab und auf einmal kommt so meine
mutter rein die haben mich dann ohne
unterwäsche oh gott das war so peinlich
wie endlich war mit kollegen feiern war
oben
ich war mit kollegen feiern was in
welchen zusammenhang es irgendwie mit
der story
okay die story hat intel zusammen er
schreibt mir eine mail des ergenzinger
sind sich sein handy genommen hatte ich
ein paar socken gefordert da kam dann
reiner die ohne unterwäsche gesehen
danke für diesen wirklich hammer
freikommt sagte ich bin dein größter
verdienst würde ich persönlich
kennenlernen bei einer freundin auf die
kacke zu hauen somit wie kennen lernen
zusammen mit einer freundin auf die
kacke hauen können
warum warum ich hoffe dich du bist cool
conny www herzlich willkommen rebsorte
kreisschau in deinen videos nur rein und
gleich dazu landen korrekt
danke an sich an der stelle das mache
ich schon seit einigen wochen dadurch
ziemlich unglücklich wird noch eine
richtig hässliche brille trägt sage ich
an dieser stelle die größte mit geworden
die unterste schicht der unter menschen
darstellen
an der stelle oder wat dann richtig oder
dem motivierenden worte und falls sie
jetzt glaubt dass ich nein es wird oder
ähnliches nein ich bin jetzt nicht ich
bin nur erstaunt dass durch eine
mitgestalten du es bist so viele nicht
autark denken nach die region feiern
allerdings sieht man an deinem großen
dislike balken wie unbeliebt du willst
bitte nehmt ihr das leben oder
verschwinde wenigstens aus dem internet
mit freundlichen grüßen in dein größter
hafen
das hat mich sehr getroffen dort wartet
schon wieder meine damen und herren wenn
ihr nicht verließ mich bei 4.000
leichtfertig mich ja dir pendant mal die
eingebettet werden könnte main kanal
abonnieren doch ein gewehr und eine
andere video verpisst euch auch nicht so
gemein und ballack